we i'm i'm a big believer in deadlines
but it's like they're self-imposed but
when you do the when you did the the
song that won the academy award that's a
movie's coming out when how fast that
one was so that's okay that's a great
example of like
just a sort of that's a that was a
lifelong dream of ours was we've always
thought that the bond music pairings
were so cool right especially these the
ones that were coming out while we were
growing up like our contemporary films
which were the daniel craig films that
the songs were like adele and um sam
smith jack white
alicia keys chris cornell i think that's
the the pantheon of the daniel craig
series um that was a thing that we
after billy's first album had come out
we sort of said to our team
hey
if you guys hear if you get win that
there's another bond movie being made
let us
like go beg for that like like we'd love
to try to impress them enough that we
get the job and so our team set about
uh talking to the people at mgm and
talking to barbara brockley that
wonderful producer
and so it was this kind of long process
of meeting them convincing them that we
um were
passionate about it and that it was
important to us i think that was like
the the most important thing to us was
that they knew that we had kind of a
reverence for the process we're like we
really want to do this it's not just
like yeah sure you know right and and
that was very much an audition they
right they really
when you are when you are auditioning
when you're having that meeting how far
into the film is the film even in
production the film was in production
when we were meeting barbara she was
flying she flew to ireland from nearby
where they were filming the movie at the
time
uh we were playing a show so she flew
out to see our show and meet with us and
we just happened to have like a great
show that day we were
it was one of those funny things where
you get off stage like like like when
you're trying to impress somebody and
you have an amazing stand-up set you're
like crap so glad that's the one they
came to um so we felt really good about
it we met with her she told us a little
bit about the film she gave us the first
20 pages of the script to read and was
like
we'd love to hear what you come up with
he's very like
noncommittal totally non-committal which
i respect why would they commit to to
using us if we're going to write a
terrible song like they don't know so
and if there's a release date right
yeah so there's a delivery date for you
yeah i mean there was definitely there
was definitely sort of a submit by date
for sure of like this is when they would
like so how long between they say write
a song to delivery of a date
i remember when we'd read the script i
remember tony seiler at billy's label
who was one of our sort of um liaisons i
remember him saying like
probably in about a week
no
no from the time we were sitting down
like are you kidding you guys have
anything and i remember because we were
on tour we were in texas
uh playing the festival austin c limits
which is a two weekend festival i know
what that is yeah super fun and so it
was that week we had first weekend and
then we were on tour in texas
bookended by those two weekends and i
remember i think we rented such an
interesting weird story i think we
rented a studio from the the hanson
brothers from the ben hanson pop in uh
from i think that was in tulsa he was in
tulsa
and uh and we we went in there for a day
and we were so
you look like a hanson brother that's
right and i was home i was homeschooled
like a hanson just not for religious
reasons which is different than the
hansen's but yeah yeah
um
anyway so we were in this hansen studio
for one day they were super friend i
think they unlocked the studio for us
they were very kind um and billy and i
were billy and i really wanted to write
something great and we had that
performance anxiety thing where we were
just like we can't make anything today
and so so you have a week i want to go
because i find this fascinating sure
because it's like netflix says we want
to give you a special but they'll give
you four or five months to put together
so you have a week do you know the title
we did we knew the title and i knew i i
had a lot of goals in mind i was like i
really want the song to be the same
title that's not always the case of the
bond themes sometimes and you know what
the story is we knew the first 20 pages
so we
don't even know how it ends no we didn't
know
spoiler the movie's been out for a while
we didn't know he was going to die
so
the title was time to die no time to die
so you didn't read the whole title
that's right yes
anyway so
yeah we had this one day in the hansen
studio where we made nothing and then
the next three days were show days i
believe we're down in the basement of
the arena where billy's playing and
i started playing the piano part which
became the song and it was one of those
sort of like i think this is the right
track
and then as songs sometimes do when
you're lucky it just sort of spilled out
over the course of i think a day
[Music]